before becoming the biggest land
predator on the planet
polar bears are born small and helpless
they must then embark on an odyssey to
grow more than a hundred times their
weight and learn everything they need to
survive before their mother abandons
them at two and a half years old
less than 50 percent will survive
i think our little bear's got a problem
here
the arctic is no place for cute
at first glance the arctic feels
brutally devoid of life
though a select group of animals have
figured out a way to thrive
but the real force here works quietly
underfoot
every winter sea ice starts small and
delicate then it grows over millions of
square miles
how is it possible that this freezer
holds the key to our entire planet
like a lung sea ice breathes life into
the arctic every year
in a cycle that impacts the climate
across the globe this is the story from
the edge of the canadian arctic where it
all starts
my name's bertie gregory and i'm a
national geographic wildlife filmmaker
everything is at stake
we're all waiting for the big freeze
as winter slowly gives way to spring on
the edge of the arctic
polar mothers break out of their dens
and get ready for a treacherous 40-mile
trek to hunt at sea
finding them in this massive featureless
landscape is nearly impossible unless
you're this guy
[Music]
maurice spence has been combing this
area for more than 40 years
well it looks like marx is already onto
something it's crazy what he can pick up
on looking at little marks in the ground
that i just drive right past
[Music]
it could be on an edgy lake like this
could be anywhere
[Music]
can't quite believe we've found this
beautiful female palmer
i say we found her i had nothing to do
with it it was all down to our
incredible pole there track of morris
but most importantly between her legs
snuggled up it's a tiny tiny little
polar bear cub
and you can see it's so tightly snuggly
above
and that's really key because right now
it doesn't have a lot of body fat that
fur isn't that thick so it's really got
to rely on mum to keep water
this cub might look small now but with
only a 60-day gestation period
polar bears are born the size of a
squirrel and weigh less than two pounds
inside the den
so this little one has been building his
strength in preparation for the big wide
world above ground
[Music]
just imagine how exciting everything
must be for that little cub i mean all
it's ever known is a dark little snow
den and then all of a sudden mum punches
out a big hole and it's got all these
new smells and sounds and the blue sky
and you know the trees
she puts up with quite a bit when you
have one cup because that's all she got
to play with
there's no little brother and sister to
pick on but the mother
[Music]
polar bear litters in the hudson bay are
getting smaller as declining sea ice
means females have less time to fatten
up before entering their dents
so if this mother wants her only cub to
survive she'll need to ensure it masters
the important game of recognizing which
smells to trust
and which ones to run away from
you can see her taking big sniffs into
the air
and i'm sure part of that is smelling us
checking out what we are
but the biggest threat to these cubs
are wolves because while she can take on
one wolf no problem the problem is the
wolves
work as a pack and work together and can
separate the two of them
[Music]
this mother faces a really tough
decision
the more she waits the stronger the cub
will be for the trek
but the mother hasn't had a good meal in
eight months and if she waits too long
her milk is going to dry up
and there they go
off on their
40 mile trek to the sea that little tiny
polar bear cub has the next two two and
a half years to learn everything that it
needs to know from its mum about how to
be a polar bear
morris has found her day dead
pretty deep
she made this right after breaking out
the hibernation dead
it's warm
to think what the actual den must be
like you know unfortunately it's blown
in so we can't get in it but to be
totally enclosed
um straight out the elements you know
this snow and ice is such a good
insulator that is well the perfect way
to conserve your energy over the winter
while you're raising these little cubs
here's some fur you know this is really
their secret weapon against the cold
so cool
after two and a half years of being
inseparable
polar bear cubs wake up to a hard truth
mum is gone
[Music]
she's got to start another breeding
cycle
well we've caught up with this little
bear and now that it's on its own it's
in
the toughest year of its life it's lost
the best bouncer in the world it's mum
who would you know back it up through
anything and also hunt for it
and now
it's got to do everything for itself so
it's got a really tough time ahead of it
[Music]
this little bear's got to be really
really resourceful i don't know what
it's got maybe some frozen berries or
something under the snow but it's got
its butt in here digging a little hole
it's definitely eating something you see
it's jaw it's your chomp
[Music]
it takes time to get used to this
solitary life
lesson number one never let your guard
down
wait
what's that smell
you've smelt this before
what is it
[Music]
[Music]
wolves
[Music]
i think our little bear's got a problem
here
[Music]
that bear's got to be overheating that
coat this is secret weapon there's got
to be a curse now
if it can just get to the water that
wolf is not going to fall away
[Music]
life is certainly not a playground
around here
but through baptism by fire this little
cub has learned an invaluable lesson
and she's one step closer to joining the
ranks of the biggest predators in the
arctic
[Music]
[Music]
you